another thing that dr bryant is not  allowed to do at the foundation he is  not allowed to make himself the king of  anywhere or queen thanks to his scp-963  necklace dr bright can steal the bodies  of pretty much any non-anomalous being  including powerful heads of states and  monarchs this would definitely be a  sweet gig for dr bright who could kick  back and enjoy all the benefits of  royalty the problem is the foundation  needs him to work for them and if ever  the necklace is removed from the ruler  they just drop dead so it's best to keep  dr bright away from anyone in a position  of power when he's in one of his more  capricious moods